hello this is Matthew from simply
learned and today we're gonna dig into
docker swarm so what we're gonna do in
this session is we're going to go
through what docker and Rocket container
is and why you'd want to use it will
then break out what are the
characteristics and structure of a
docker swarm environment and then
finally we'll go through and do a demo
using actual code in the command line
interface to actually run and build out
the main functions and commands that you
would use for a docker swamp environment
so with that said let's get started so
doctors a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're cheap building and
testing and validating codes that's
being created think of it as a
virtualization but much more
sophisticated and efficient way of doing
virtualization the thing that you have
that's a huge advantage when you're
working with docker is that it's a very
lightweight software package it allows
you to have all of the tools needed for
actually running the code without having
to have the significant overhead that
you would normally have with
virtualization so one of the
characteristics you have with docker is
that you can actually run multiple
documents in the same host environment
and for you to be able to do this we had
to figure out how this would actually
run and so to actually do this we
actually do what's called a docker swarm
and a docker swarm is an environment
where you can actually have multiple
docker images running on the same host
operating system so you can have running
in each of those docker containers
different solutions so let's dig into
what a docker swarm is so a docker swarm
is essentially a tool that allows you to
very easily create and schedule multiple
docker nodes so really two or more
docker nodes and you can have quite a
large number of docker nodes in a single
swarm each node itself is actually
docker daemon and that demon is able to
interact with the doctor API and have
all the benefits of being a full docker
environment one of the other advantages
you have is that the
each container with and thus one can
then be deployed and managed but as a
node in that entire clustered
environment so what we have here is a
breakdown of the five key elements
within a doctor environment you have the
docker container you have the daemon the
docker images and the docker client and
docker registry so the doctor daemon
itself is what does all the work
interacting with the actual host
operating system to be able to manage
the docker containers so if we look here
here we have set up an environment where
we have three docket container being run
with docker and what we want to be able
to do is a bale to interact with the
environment because what would happen if
we actually have something change in our
environment so we have the environment
setup as a docker swarm and one of our
containers fails what we were able to do
is use the swarm to be able to correct
that failure so the docker swarm manager
is able to come in and reschedule
containers and as you would imagine the
actual swarm node has full backups and
full redundancy for any kind of failures
that would happen and we would do all of
this work through command-line interface
so let's go through some of the features
that you have within the agile docker
swarm itself so a key feature for docker
swarm is that it is fully decentralized
which means that it makes it very easy
for teams to be able to access and
manage the environment as you would
expect as well is that the communication
that happens between the manager and
client nodes would end the swamp is
highly secure and of course this is
really just a fundamental that you
should have for any kind of solution but
it is good to know that docker swarm has
that built in there is also auto load
balancing within your environment and
you can actually script that into how
you write out and structure your swarm
environment and that load balancing then
also allows you to then convert that
swarm environment into a highly scalable
infrastructure and then rollback tasks
allows you to be able to rollback
environments to previous safe
environments
say something that does get pushed out
and something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually have to
be breast services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment and each of the
different services contains a group of
containers of the same image now by
having this structure allows you to be
able to scale your application
appropriate to the demands on your
service so if you have a service that
needs to have a significantly larger
number of services for it to run you can
actually scale that appropriately and
they can be either geo or demand based
one of the requirements for setting up a
Davos forum is you must have at least
one node deployed so the way that the
architecture is set up is that you have
a manager node and a client node and
there must be one of each for the entire
environment to be able to work
effectively so you know here we are just
jumping ahead of sales a little bit we
have two types of nodes in a docker
swamp we have the manager node and we
have the worker node which is the client
that does the actual execution of the
tasks the manager node very similar to
other systems that we've talked about on
simply learn allows you to actually
control and manage the actual tasks that
are being executed by the worker nodes
and the worker nodes as you can imagine
then actually execute the instructions
that the manager are sending out to it
so here we have a situation where we can
illustrate what would happen with a
manager node sending out commands to
different worker nodes the manager is
fully aware of the status of the entire
swarm environment at all times this is
because of the two-way secure
communication that's going from the
manager to the worker environment the
workers as you'd expect are accepting
tasks that are being sent from the
manager so the manager sends out a task
saying that you need to be running as a
my sequel environment then the worker
node will then convert to a my sequel
environment and all these environments
are scripted and controlled by you as
the manager the actual worker nodes
themselves actually have a client agent
and that client
we'll then communicate all different
states of the infrastructure back to the
manager so that anytime the manager node
is in full control of the entire swarm
the major is the controller office
environment and so you always want to be
able to ensure that the manager has full
access to all the work that's happening
within the swarm and this allows you as
the manager to control your swarm and
very quickly be able to react to any
changes without having to rely on manual
installations of software and hardware
and as we covered earlier on there is a
REST API that uses the communication
over HTTP from the manager to the worker
node it's interesting to note that it is
a REST API because if you wanted to you
could actually integrate that API into
custom applications and even then create
automated docket images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that they're really a big
advantage with having a swarm is that
once you've actually created the swarm
any of the services that you create can
be accessed by any node of the same
cluster one of things you do have to do
though is you have to specify what
container image that you're going to use
when you're creating a new service and
you can do that either through a
centralized docker hub environment or
through your own private docker hub
environment one of the things that's
interesting is that you can set up
commands and services to be either
global or replicated a global service
will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey isn't a
service and tasks the same thing no they
kind of not in the docker world and the
differences is a service is a
description of a task or the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
is a document users you actually create
services and then you can then define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this part you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to worker nodes in which they
have the capability of a manager but
they are dependent on that single
primary manager to be able to provide
the right instructions and for services
and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command-line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via API and that those API is
that we connect to in our song
environment allows us to do
orchestration by tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their IP address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager node to
be able to check for when tasks come in
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager node to
the work node so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build alright so with
that said let's go ahead and we're gonna
do a demo so we're gonna go ahead and go
do a demo and showing how you can run
with docker swan for this you'll need to
have both a virtual environment where
your manager and your working
environment so here we have our worker
and here we have our manager so we're
just gonna open up terminal window and
we're gonna go into the manager for a
terminal window so the following command
here is used to initialize docker suam
just going to type this in
so sudo docker swan in it and we push
the IP address for the network we're
connecting to and open our password and
here we
connected and this is our manager node
and what we want to be able to highlight
is the specific token which identifies
the docker swarm environment and this is
our token right here so we're going to
copy that because we will need to use
that for our work our environment so
here we are in the working environment
and we'll use the token that we just
copied as a way to be able to connect to
the manager and connect to the docker
swarm environment and so sudo
I'll paste in the Duggar swagman will
join that I would now here we shows that
we have joined the swarm environment as
a worker and now we're in the manager we
can actually show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node LS to list out all
of the items in that environment
so we actually been the wrong area so we
write pseudo-code note at LS to list out
all the nodes in the Swan and there you
see we've actually connected the worker
to the manager node and both our active
and the manager is the leader and the
work of VirtualBox is in the swarm
okay we're gonna go ahead and create a
new service so dr. Swan create and we're
going to just change the name to hello
world for the new service and we use the
Alpine image from docker comm takes just
a moment for it to run
you know here we go and there we go
service has converged so what we have
now is a new service that has been
created let's go ahead and we'll list
out the services and here we have a new
HelloWorld service
when we go ahead and check the duck
Tanner's and we're going to Ducker PS
and here's our Alpine it's running the
latest image and that's the docket
container ID
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node and make sure
everything is working over there
so go over to our workout paste that in
so what we see here is there is no
imagery or continued credit because it's
not in the worker node it would be in
imagine owed so he go ahead and create
the new service
and we will make the mote global and
that way the service is available across
all of the swamp so we're just going to
execute that work takes a moment and
there we are done work has been
completed and we have the two different
IDs which shows on two different
services running and if we go back to
the worker mode and we run sudo FPS
again and there we are now we see that
we have the hello world new virtual
environment has been added with the
image of Alpine and we also have the new
token ID for that
if we want to kill a node from the swamp
we can use the find command which tsuita
doukasen leave - - force and that will
force the node to leave the swamp thank
you for hanging with us here as we go
through a docker swarm architecture hope
you've learned some great new techniques
allow you to hopefully effectively
manage a docker swarm environment if you
have any questions please post them
below in the comments if you like this
video we have new videos coming out all
the time please hit the like and
subscribe button and then if you want to
get notified select the bell and we'll
get you notifications of every new video
that we have when it comes out this is
Matthew from simply learn and looking
forward to seeing you next time hi there
if you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here